so moving right along I'm truly
delighted to welcome next Angus Deaton
last year's laureate in economics
sciences thank us good morning it's an
enormous pleasure to be back here in
Stockholm and to talk about food I want
to talk about the other end if you like
the very poorest people in the world and
what food means to them so the simple
view that I think most people have at
least the most rich people have is that
malnutrition around the world is a
problem of poverty and of low income
which lead to poor levels of nutrition
through not having our food here indeed
is a picture of what's happening the
global poverty over the last 30 years
this innocence is a hockey stick to but
a reverse hockey stick in which up until
about nineteen ninety there was really
very little change probably increase in
the number of people in the world living
on under two dollars a day but then
since 1990 over the last twenty or
thirty years there's been one of the
greatest triumphs in human history which
is a reduction of more than a billion
people who have come out of abject
destitution towards something like a
tolerable if only barely tolerable for
some people living standard so while all
these terrible things have been going on
in the planet one of the high plains has
been this enormous reduction in global
poverty now is that the same extent
shown up in human nutrition well in some
ways yes but in some ways no so I'm
going to talk here today about adult
height
adult height is an indicator of
nutritional outcomes rather than
nutritional intake which we think of as
food so I want to look at it but the
chain that goes from food intake perhaps
largely determined by income so the
outcomes in in personal nutrition as
measured by how tall people are now
adult height is likely set in early
childhood and it sent my net nutritional
levels this is a very important
distinction because its intake food is
important but so are the things that
come out the tolls on the body
particularly they might have work
children have to do I'm the state of
sanitation in particular and the thing
about adult height is once you get to
adulthood and you attain your your full
height it doesn't change very much at
least before age 50 now that means that
in a growing economy where people are
getting better and nourished older
people tend to be shorter than younger
people because the older people had less
good nutrition when they were kids than
younger people do now and so we can look
at the difference in height between the
elderly and the young adults as a
measure of how rapidly society is
progressing now this picture now shows
the state of heights around the world
these are women because for one reason
another you get much better data on
women and the bottom axis here shows a
measure of national income in the year
of birth and each little blob shows a
birth cohort of women and the different
colors show you different parts of the
planet the blue dots of the top right
and the red dot for the u.s. show Europe
and you can see that big arrow there
which is showing as GDP per capita has
increased over the last 20 30 years
Europeans have gotten taller I'm quite
rapidly taller especially in
northwestern your
including Sweden but if you forget about
that for the time being just look at the
country's over to the left I'm the
poorer countries in the world there's
essentially no relationship at all
between income and adult height so that
for some reason this higher income in
the better richer countries does not
tend to pay off into better adult or
child nutrition so if we summarize that
these Heights have increased with GDP
per capita in some countries has been
remarkable I mean Korea appears to hold
the record in which women in Korea have
actually grown average on average by 20
centimetres in the last hundred years
more standard around the world at least
in the richer countries has been one
centimeter per decade across poor
countries that are uncorrelated I've
talked about that alright it ready but
they're huge variability especially in
Africa and sub-saharan Africa one thing
you should note in this picture if I can
go back is I'm going to come back to
this the very bottom left brown blob
there is South Asia India and Pakistan
and I want to say a few words than that
the other thing that's very clear I
sorry it's mistake if you try to skip
too far if we come to India a little bit
which I want to talk a little bit more
Indian women and men are among the very
shortest in the world there and in the
others probably in thousands of years of
inadequate nutrition the population
crusher shrinks per-capita food supply
and shrinks people to enable them to
survive if everybody in India were
taller you couldn't maintain the size of
population that's really there but
Africans who are actually much smaller
than Indians much poorer than Indians
are actually quite a lot taller now let
me talk about India is one of the most
rapidly growing countries in terms of
GDP per capita and in terms of how much
people are spending yet adult heights
are being grown
at only half the standard rates and much
more slowly among women than men about
one-third of the male rate in fact
something like half of all Indian
children are severely and malnourished a
lot of this is to do with discrimination
against women in food and indeed in
other things this keeps down both male
and female height and growth everyone
including men has to have a mom if you
then look at this picture this is a plot
of heights by age and what is showing
here is that in India and the top the
difference between the old and the young
is much less than in neighboring
countries of Bangladesh and Nepal again
to do with discrimination if you look at
this this is for men and women in India
and you can see the men rate which is
very low by national by international
comparisons is actually very much higher
than women so the women's growth rate
women get less well fed in India than
men the last point I want to make is
about rapid rates of economic growth and
in spite of this fact per capita calorie
and protein consumption in India have
actually been falling for the last 25
years except for a very recent time
reversal now what is going on here it
seems to be that as people get richer
not only do they want more food but
that's offset by reductions in heavy
manual labor there's better roads better
water supply more mechanization and less
disease heavy work is undesirable so
that as people get richer they do less
of it and that reduces the calorie
intake which is offsetting the demand
for food from them actually getting
richer so if I can summarize my takeaway
here is that food intake is only one of
many factors setting human nutrition
that patterns of consumption are very
important to including variety of what
you eat work is incredibly important
especially in poor country
where work patterns are much higher much
more demanding than they are here and so
is public health including clean water
and sanitation so in a broader sense
it's not just growth in the market which
determines how well nourished people are
but collective action to thank you very
much
[Applause]